on march 21 2022 cd projekt red
announced the next game in the witcher
series has begun development which in
turn caused me to celebrate as if i had
just won the lottery it also brought up
a question i hadn't thought about in a
while what do i want from a witcher 3
follow-up so with elden rings still
burning on my mind i first started
writing this video with the plan of
telling you what i'd want the witcher to
take inspiration from however the
further i got into this script the more
i could hear my mind scream screw this
you're stripping all of the witcher out
so instead allow me to talk about what i
want from the next witcher game while
trying to not overdo the comparisons
so i've seen the reddit threads of
disapproval but i disagree i would love
to create my own witcher in the next
game initially i was on the fence about
this one but the more i thought about it
the more i realized that it's a change
that could work well for witcher i love
geralt but if the series is moving away
from him anyway then i'd love to step
into the boots of my own witcher and
play out my monster killing fantasy in
that way however i don't want it to be a
voiceless protagonist situation i'm
thinking more in the lines of mass
effect or cd projekt red's very own
cyberpunk 2077. each witcher would
already have a name baked into the
game's story as well as a plentiful
amount of voice dialogue choices for the
player to choose from cdpr could even
take an actual stab at real story
altering consequences to those choices
it's also worth noting that based on the
teaser this next entry will dive into
unknown territory with the school of the
links this school hasn't been explored
in any other piece of witcher media
aside from fan fiction there are also
theories that this could be a new school
that series started after witcher 3
marrying the styles of the wolf school
and the cat school but if siri isn't the
star of this next game and the lead is
an unknown witcher then why not let me
customize them
as i'm making this video there are
probably a dozen people crafting tweets
about how amazing eldon rings organic
discovery is the witcher 3 is also a
game guilty of being a joy to explore
but as i returned to the northern realms
recently i found it a little less
organic with witcher's map you're drawn
to most locations because of a looming
question mark taunting you it drives
your curiosity forward and what you find
may lead to a cool experience but it's
less of a surprise because you already
knew something was there and sure you
can filter these off of the map but it's
not permanent and they populate the
second you open the map again you can
reconfigure the hud and take
undiscovered locations off of the
mini-map or axe the hud entirely but in
the next witcher i'd like the option to
truly have an empty map to reference i'd
also love for there to be a compass at
the top of the screen so that when i do
take off the mini-map i still have a
minimal way to keep track of where i'm
headed ultimately i want the next
witcher to have some mystery but just
not as much mystery as elvenring has
what i mean by that is the witcher needs
its cutscenes it needs its main story
beats told or shown directly to the
player in a classic game way and i know
eldon ring has its cutscenes too but
it's story is mainly told through item
descriptions and context clues from
small moments of npc dialogue and that's
definitely not something i want from
witcher instead that mystery can show up
more inside content in the
moment-to-moment gameplay of getting
from point a to point b the world of the
witcher is so vast and detailed and i
think there are a ton of opportunities
for the devs to bake nuggets of intrigue
into the corners of the game there's no
denying it the witcher 3's map is big
and it does a great job of giving the
player the feeling of being in a living
breathing world however i'd love to
stand on a shore and see skelega in the
distance and sail to it instead of
sitting through a loading screen in the
next witcher i love more connectivity
with the maps different regions if
there's a palace like the one in vezima
let me travel to the city and gaze in
awe as i ride up to the palace gates let
me journey back and forth freely to this
game's version of karamorin without
loading straight into it this is a small
issue and if we're really being honest
the loads won't even matter on the ssds
of current consoles but at this point
i'm used to everything being connected
in open world games that i can't help
but expect it from the witcher as well
hopefully this doesn't seem hypocritical
to my last point but i would love a
quicker fast travel system in witcher 3
if i'm out in a field and want to get to
a town across the map i have to first
travel to the nearest signpost in order
to warp to another signpost this is slow
and unnecessary i want the next witcher
to be more like modern open worlds and
allow me to jump straight to where i
want to go without extra steps and
please don't make me use resources to
fast travel that's right i'm looking at
you horizon
it bears repeating that the world of the
witcher is large but so far in the games
we've only gotten the chance to explore
one chunk of it so in the next game i'd
love to take a trip south of the
northern kingdoms i want to know what
it's like to explore nilfgaard even
though word on the street is they suck
over there let me get lost in more
swamps and forests let me climb the
mountains and drool at the vistas that
await me let me travel to the desert and
regret it take me to wherever the school
of the lynx is and let me fall in love
with the areas that surround it
this may be hard to hear but the witcher
3's crafting system needs to calm down
resources may be everywhere you go but
the list of required ingredients per
item can still get a little overwhelming
so for the next witcher game i'd love a
simplified crafting system and a more
streamlined way of upgrading my favorite
gear shout out to the homies marcus and
nick louise for helping me brainstorm
that one and while we're talking about
crafting in gear it'd be really cool to
get a transmog system going in the new
witcher game as well that way i can have
the stats of an awesome piece of armor
but change the appearance to better
match my entire outfit
as much as i love witcher 3 i was never
crazy about how geralt handled when just
walking around the addition of the
alternate movement option definitely
made this better but it still hasn't
aids super well however i'm assuming
this will be a pretty easy fix
considering the next game will be in
unreal 5 a completely different engine
than the witcher 3 was developed in this
shift in engine should also change how
the combat feels which would also be a
welcome change the witcher 3 combat
isn't bad in my opinion but it doesn't
feel as good as it once did
my next request has nothing to do with
gameplay changes i really want honesty
and transparency from cd projekt red the
studio was riding high after the release
of witcher 3 and many fans myself
included felt that they could do no
wrong that bubble was popped when the
broken cyberpunk 2077 experience got
into player hands now the company is in
a state of repairing its image and
restoring trust with fans following the
announcement of the next witcher i saw a
mix of excitement and caution with many
fans restricting themselves for getting
too hyped about the next witcher release
even another close friend of mine and
fellow witcher enthusiasts reacted to
the news of the next game in the text
thread and said quote nice to hear but
after cyberpunk i'll have to wait on it
for me personally i was never super
excited about cyberpunk i planned on
playing it but i wasn't in the camp of
fans that thought it would be the next
evolution of rpg so when it released i
calmly decided to hold off on playing it
i wasn't let down by the train wreck
like many others were however i know for
a fact if that same situation happens
with the next witcher game
i
will be devastated so i'd love more than
anything for cdpr to learn from their
past mistakes and be honest with fans
about the progress of the project and if
it's not done then delay it into
infinity just please don't ship a broken
game or rush it to make a deadline or
sync up with the next netflix witcher
release
okay my last request is one that i'm
super unsure about but hang in there
with me i love the message system in
eldon ring and if i'm being completely
honest with myself i'd love something
similar in a witcher game however i
don't feel like it meshes with witcher
lore well and we also don't need a
kikimura encounter preceded by a dog
ahead try gesture message this seems
more like a feature for a witcher mmo
something else i'd be mildly interested
in
so to recap i want a character creator
more organic exploration with a compass
and seamlessly connected regions from
witcher lore that we've never explored
before better fast travel better
movement and developer transparency so
did i nail it or did i nail it hit the
comment section and let me know what you
really want from the next witcher game
and make sure you're subscribed to
gamespot so that when more information
about the game comes out you can stay
informed thanks for watching
[Music]